all right we are continuing to take your
call six one seven eight three zero four
seven five zero who is on with me today
hey Dave it's Andrew Andrew how are you
you're the last caller today so I know
you're going to have a absolutely
fantastic question um yeah I was curious
as to why you think that the right wing
is so obsessed with what people do in
the bedroom why are they so obsessed
with it well I I mean I think it depends
which right-wingers some resummon sort
of religiously oriented for some it's
sort of repressed feelings where they
are so repressed in their sexuality that
they want to dictate what other people
are doing in the bedroom I I think it
sort of depends on which which brand or
flavor of right-winger you're talking
about what other combinations are there
well I mean and then you can attack it
from different sides there are other
politicians who want nobody to have sex
it seems unless yours very specifically
procreating and while you're married of
course naturally and then there are the
ones who say that well nobody who's gay
can have sex with someone of the same
sex and and for them there is a lot of
that repression and we find out that
many of those people who are the most
what's the word passionately anti-gay
yeah do end up be having gay feelings
themselves so it is there is a wide
spectrum what's your assessment of where
that obsession comes from yeah yeah what
like what's your take on what causes
that obsession yeah it's a tough one to
figure out that's the power Oh anti-gay
things it seems so antiquated I know
it's like who even cares it's all it's
for me it's it makes such little sense
to even be concerned with that and I'm
sort of being facetious here but it's
almost kind of quaint when someone is
still against two guys being in a
relationship around like wow that's so
kind of cute it's like you're from
years ago you're not even really like a
modern person you know dude what else do
you believe that makes no sense and I'm
sort of kidding obviously that type of
ideology is still really hateful but I
just don't get how is anyone spending
any time on being worried about two guys
being together you know yeah I mean I
have two nieces or 11 and 14 years old
and they know gay couples single lesbian
couples and they don't think anything
about it oh yeah I mean I have a 12 year
old I have a 12 year old sister and I've
mentioned this she has been relatively
sheltered fortunately until recently
about the fact that it's even
controversial to have like two moms or
two dads
she knows parents who gave parents who
have adopted she knows she has friends
at school who have a parent that was in
a relationship in a heterosexual
relationship when they had my sister's
friend since then got divorced and now
is in a same-sex relationship she has
barely any even awareness of the fact
that how could someone could be angry
about that or think that it's bad what
does that even mean and I think it's
just a sign of the times you know that
generation it truly unless it's
ingrained to them very aggressively by
their parents many of them don't even
know about what's been going on around
that issue in this country these
politicians until appealing to I mean
yeah I mean they're raising money to
deal with their base you can still raise
money around that's what's keeping it
the last vestiges of that are around
because you're able to raise money from
religious communities and in certain
areas but less so and I think that's a
good thing all right with that that
wraps up phone calls thanks so much for
being our last caller today really
really appreciate it we will take calls
again the number will continue to be 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 and with that we will take
a break